joe tell us what's going on with ftx ftx
uh seems to be shelling out
all the money for sponsorship deals
what's going on with fdx yeah so it's no
surprise we talk about it all the time
the crypto market has exploded in value
over the last few years if you look at
the total market cap of all uh digital
assets
it was essentially 1 billion to 10
billion for a long exterior depend a
long period of time before 2017 in 2017
it ran up to 750 billion and this year
it ran up to 2.4 billion so we had a
kind of a elapsed uh a bear market
between in 2018 2019 and what we saw is
that uh in this last run up all the
crypto exchanges have exploded in
valuation they're printing more money
than ever before and they uh are
creating more transactional revenue than
ever before and one of those companies
is ftx so ftx wasn't uh an established
brokerage in an except established
exchange in 2017 they started in 2019.
in 2019 they were creating average daily
revenue of about 40 000
by 2020 that was 235 000
and this year they're doing 2.2 million
dollars in revenue per day so that's
about 800 million dollars in annual
revenue the run rate that they're at
which is up from 80 million dollars in
total revenue last year so the business
has exploded it's about 10x up in total
revenue this year they think that
there's a chance they might reach 1
billion in total revenue so
they're not alone in this they've kind
of been at the forefront of it though
announcing a bunch of these news and the
reason why we wanted to talk about them
was because they've been super active in
sports so what they're doing is they've
agreed to a bunch of different
partnerships so one of them uh the first
one they did was with the miami heat
they did a naming rights deal uh with
their arena for 135 million dollars over
19 years first crypto sponsor first
crypto exchange to sponsor a major us
professional sports venue after that
they went and did one with tsm which is
an esports organization slightly
different deal because they're actually
adding the ftx name to the overall name
of the organization instead of just the
naming rights but that was 210 million
or 21 million dollars annually so a
massive uh equity commitment a massive
financial commitment uh compared to the
nba deal and then they've signed a bunch
of other ones so yesterday they
announced a 17.5 million dollar deal to
rename cal's football field ftx field
they paid the entire deal in crypto uh
to learfield who did the who brokered
the deal for cal and then we've seen
them do they did a five-year deal with
mlb uh they signed tom brady and giselle
to a ambassador deal where tom brady
actually received equity in the company
uh and received payment in crypto so
we've seen a bunch of these trevor
lawrence had a deal with blockfolio
which is uh kind of a subsidiary of ftx
and he was paid in crypto we've seen a
bunch with crypto.com and a few of these
other exchanges and really what i think
it says is we're going to start seeing
these become commonplace really we've
seen uh athletes sign deals we've seen
team sign deals and we've seen league
sign deals some of them accept payment
and crypto and some don't but i think
what we're going to see is we're going
to see over the next few years as this
market continues to mature and becomes a
multiple a multi-billion dollar
multi-trillion dollar industry that this
money is going to continue to flow and
we're going to see billions of dollars
flow into sports specifically ftx has
been a leader in it from an investment
standpoint so far but when these
companies are are printing so much cash
and generating so much cash from a
transactional perspective they're going
out to acquire new customers and retain
new customers uh through marketing and
marketing depending on kind of where
your business is located is most likely
a tax deductible expense so what do you
do when you have 800 million 800 billion
dollars of revenue uh 800 million
dollars of revenue up 10x from last year
you go and you acquire new customers
through different channels and we've
seen that the data is obviously showing
them that sports is one of those
channels that they can uh see a good
return on and we were talking about it
earlier like one of the things all these
companies have to determine is what is
the best use of this capital right is it
is it investing in new products or new
uh new people hiring doing all these
things expanding the business etc is it
marketing and what we've seen with ftx
and some of these other brokerages uh is
that they're they're putting an
aggressive amount of their capital that
they're turning off their business back
into sports they're doing it with
individual players teams and leagues and
i think we're going to continue to see
that happen over the next few years
is there a thing where ftx has just
realized nobody had breached sports yet
and that was like the mainstream
audience that basically uh all the
crypto companies were simply marketing
to people already in crypto and they
said no way we have to go find new
people sports is like the best avenue to
do that is that what's going on yeah
well i think traditionally most people
uh you can go a couple different routes
right so marketing within crypto and
people that were interested in crypto
was obviously the place to start right
you want to kind of get the market share
as much land as you can grab immediately
within kind of the industry that you're
focused on but then i think what they
said is like outside of traditional
finance if we can't convince someone
who's investing in stocks and and bonds
and all these other things in real
estate to come over to crypto what
industry do we tact do we attack and i
think for most companies including ftx
who led the way on this is that they
realized that the overlap was massive in
sports right so uh if you're kind of
someone who was interested in financial
markets the largest category that
overlapped with was traditionally sports
and these uh depending on kind of what
leagues and organizations you attacked
sometimes they're uh kind of they make
the most from the financial standpoint
right from there's so many different
avenues you can sponsor right so like
even uh you can even the oakland a's
were selling uh suites in in crypto
right like there's just so many
different ways to market it and get
exposure and impressions and engagement
off of it that i think ftx said look
this is probably the best avenue and
let's just aggressively attack it
immediately
it feels like sam uh really understands
risk reward uh for those that don't know
sam bankman freed was one of the i think
two top donors to joe biden's
presidential campaign and i heard an
interview where he was talking somebody
asked him about you know why did you
donate it was like 5 million bucks or so
uh to joe biden's campaign and he
basically walked through a risk-reward
analysis of okay i'm going to spend 5
million here is the impact it can have
this is like one of the most lopsided
investments that i could make in terms
of risk reward and so if that is the
mentality he uses for a donation to a
political campaign it feels like sam and
his team has probably scoured all of
sports trying to locate and understand
where should they actually go and
invest so when we see them do things
like the miami heat arena or tsm or
cal's stadium
do we have any understanding as to why
those specific assets like why miami
heat arena versus anyone else is it just
that that one was up and for the naming
rights or something else yeah so the
miami heat deal was unique in the aspect
that
the team doesn't actually own the
ability to go out and negotiate that
deal it's actually owned by miami the
city so miami purchased the rights on
that a while ago and they're essentially
they have within the contract that they
have to pay the miami heat some sum of
money i think it's like one to two
million dollars per year regardless of
who has the deal so the the naming
rights had actually been vacant for the
past year american airlines arena is
still the official name for broadcast
and their name is on the building
technically but that deal ended a year
or two ago so there was no one that had
taken over that for a year and
essentially american airlines either got
like a heavily discounted or essentially
a free sponsorship for a year so maybe
it was that risk reward you're talking
about and sam went to miami and said hey
look this arena naming rights is vacant
you're not getting the dollars that you
thought you were gonna get i'll come in
and i'll pay this and it obviously
worked out they agreed to the deal uh
miami got some capital back from what
they probably missed the city of miami
for what they had missed previously and
were able to pay the heat now and i
think they're making uh you know a few
million bucks a year off of it now but
the other thing that's interesting to
think about
is uh
is what else they've attacked right and
they've gone after a bunch of other
sports mlb crypto.com has gone after
formula one the ufc so my point earlier
was just really about how many diverse
assets there are to sponsor you can go
kind of across the ecosystem and there's
it's global crypto's global right so the
sports leagues that are traditionally
thought of as global are uh the premier
league formula one nfl to some degree
but it's mostly american right so you
have to look at it from the perspective
of where is the data telling us that we
want to pick up the customers and where
are the sports leagues attacking so
crypto.com was a good example in formula
one because they paid a hundred million
dollars i think or something like that
and they get access to every single race
on the calendar if you look at some of
the pictures i'll we'll pull them up
later but they they have their logo as
just massive on the track and there's
some degree of like active advertising
versus passive but i think at the same
time
formula one races they attract 90
million fans per race which is the
equivalent of a super bowl here in the
nfl right so from a a global perspective
crypto companies are unique where
they're looking for that uh global reach
and i think these partnerships are
certainly kind of one way to do it and
then you attack certain
assets within other markets so the miami
heats arena is one here locally in miami
that will have kind of reached across
the u.s as it is broadcasted across nba
is there one opportunity that you
haven't seen yet that you're like oh
somebody should go do this like is there
whether it's a team a facility a league
a certain type of sport like should
somebody go sponsor the next cricket
team or like how do you think about yeah
honestly i think we're still pretty
early right like there's only been uh
probably like less than 10 big
sponsorships so there's been like like
grayscale sponsored the new york giants
right but most people don't know about
it because it's a smaller sponsorship uh
not only from a dollar amount but from
an advertising kind of minimum
requirement perspective right they get
some video assets and they're on some of
the social media channels and stuff like
that but then there's the big ones that
make all the news where uh right like
the cal one yesterday was 17.5 million
dollars it was you know a small
percentage of what ftx has spent in
general i think they've spent almost 500
million dollars now so just a small
percent of what they've done but it made
the news because they paid 100 in crypto
right so i think that's what we're
seeing is we're seeing a lot of these
brands try to get unique and telling
athletes or businesses or leagues or
teams or whatever it is hey except
portion of this encrypto right like it's
obviously what we believe in we hold it
on our balance sheets we have the assets
all this stuff and it'll make it more
marketable so we see athletes that
obviously believe in the business and
want to be paid in crypto and all this
stuff but in the day it's usually
typically a smaller portion of their
portfolio and it gives it that marketing
power of like this tweet's going to go
viral this news is going to go viral
it's going to be everywhere
john what do you think beautifully said
i'm glad you brought up crypto.com um
i watch sports i watch f1 and i notice
right away it's it's also it's really
about that like active versus passive
advertising right so when you watch an
f1 race you see crypto.com literally on
there when you watch a ufc event you see
crypto.com the grayscale with uh the
giants was a little different because
they're not actually like
when you go to the game or anything like
that you don't see their name uh you
only see it kind of on the internet uh
like that so it's just it's a different
type of sponsorship it's really
interesting to see which one's more
valuable and obviously the one that puts
their name right in your face is
definitely more valuable yeah i was uh i
was uh surprised to some degree but i
was happy to see the crypto.com deal
with f1 because i believe that's when
you talk about sports that hadn't been
infiltrated that was the one that i
would have pointed to because it's a
global reach right so crypto is a global
asset class and it gives them reach
across kind of every country every
industry all this type of stuff but not
only that it hadn't been penetrated by
any other crypto companies and it's the
least monetized uh sport right so when
you think about the nfl premier league
all these other leagues if you looked at
it on a per fan basis first how much
dollars they generate that's the the uh
the multiple that f1 has is the smallest
why because they just don't do
traditionally it's an ass it's a super
uh asset like business right so all they
do is from operationally they just do
the uh the broadcasting deals so they go
out and negotiate broadcasting deals
with every country uh to display their
races but they don't own any of the
teams they don't own any of the tracks
right so every race that they have they
actually get paid a fee right so if you
go to monaco monaco is not a great
example because it's uh the most famous
race so they pay the smallest fee but
maybe they pay five 10 15 million
dollars another track and they get to
hold the race and then it's up to them
to make a profit right so you just got
to sell the rights
to come there and then f1 says all right
pay me 15 million dollars and then you
as the track you can sell all your stuff
there you can you know you do all the
hospitality you do the tickets you build
the track you do all of that and then f1
sells sponsorships so sponsorships is
the one main category that they're going
to try to build up now because there's
broadcasting and i think part of that is
the digital people right so amazon and
all these i think will and netflix if
they get super into the sports business
and they start doing live rights i think
they're going to go after f1 because
it's one of the only sports leagues that
is truly global right so premier league
everyone watches in the world formula
one is that other sport that's truly
global nfl mlb mba we all watch it here
in the us but not everyone watches it no
one cares about it in other countries
really right so when you think about
global reach f1 is a great sport and
then those fees are super low still
because they haven't been able to
monetize it aggressively they've hired
new leadership they transaction
transitioned out an old ceo a while ago
who was one of the original founders and
stuff but i think what we'll see is
we'll see them try to aggressively uh
get that multiple up over time because
it's a wealthy sport the fan base of f1
is uh traditionally wealthier than other
sports leagues so i think we'll see that
increase
but i think it was smart off crypto.com
to get in early and say hey look 90
million people watch this every single
weekend there's 25 races a year on
average and 90 million people are going
to watch it and sure there's a sum
that's kind of the same and it's
stagnant advertising versus 30 second
commercials but when you think about it
like a super bowl commercial for 30
seconds goes for a few million bucks
they paid 100 million for 25 races over
five years 25 each year over five right
so like the value there uh is much more
than you would see in a traditional
league so that was one that i thought
would point out that that would be
pointed out for like a value perspective
but i think we'll see it across others
right like premier league is another
asset the nfl all these all these
leagues are going to get into it because
it's going to be billions of dollars of
capital flowing into the advertising
space what happens in these deals if the
company goes out of business
like i'm not predicting that for any of
these businesses but i'm just saying
like let's say uh a business says to f1
hey we're in for 25 years or 10 years
sponsorship or whatever and five or ten
years five years into the deal uh the
company goes out of business or it's
acquired and the new acquirer doesn't
want to continue to honor the contract
like what happens yeah well fee so i
haven't seen uh the specifics of any of
these necessarily but my guess would be
that it's all based on risk right so you
have someone underwriting the contract
that's saying hey look uh you know this
company's not super liquid they don't
have a long track record they've only
been around for two or three years the
business has exploded in this boom uh so
maybe we require 50 paid up front sixty
percent paid up maybe a hundred percent
paid up up front right so there's some
degree of like those things you can
manipulate and then yeah there's breakup
fees and all this stuff but the one
thing i would point out that i thought
was super interesting uh was sam uh sam
bankman freed uh with ftx he said when
he was asked about the miami heat deal
he went out and they did the miami heat
deal for 135 and then they did tsm right
after that for 210 and people were like
uh essentially made that point of like
hey dude what if you can't pay these
deals off in in 10 20 years that you've
already signed these for and he made
some comment uh i'd have to find it to
quote him correctly and i don't want to
uh misinterpret it but essentially what
he said was don't worry about it we have
enough money right now to pay for him
so like these companies like people
understand i was saying the stats
earlier they made 80 million dollars in
transactional revenue last year they're
gonna make 800 to a billion this year
they've exploded in value you know what
i mean so they're just printing cash
right now from a transaction standpoint
and they're going out and deploying it
so sam's like dude we have 200 million
if we need to pay for it right now we
could we're going to be liquid over the
next few years we're expanding we think
this is where we're going to be and at
the end of the day they just underwrite
the contracts to that risk hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it